I'm just looking at some of those really
concerning unemployment numbers how
worried are you the about the jobs
picture in the United Kingdom as the
furlough scheme is one down really
worries the jobs market is on red alert
and we're very clear that the government
can't afford to stand on their sidelines
and watch good firms go bust and and
jobs goes to the wall I think what we've
seen too often is a pattern of dithering
a PR announcement rushed last-minute
consultation no planning poor delivery
and instead what we need is a real
laser-like focus on how we protect jobs
and firms and keep that demand going in
the economy so that we can bounce back
quicker the Sunday Telegraph is
reporting that ministers are looking at
plans for a retraining revolution to try
and help a meat like mitigate some of
the impact of the job losses is that
something that you'd like to see skills
have a big part to play but what we need
I think is some bold thinking I mean we
were I hope central to the development
of the wage subsidy scheme that furlough
scheme that has saved 9 million
livelihoods and also support for the
self-employed but what we need now is to
make sure that we can reopen the economy
by making sure that firms are safe
number one that's the quickest way to
get more people back at work but also to
have the jobs guarantee and targeted
support for industries we don't want
industries going off the cliff edge come
October and one thought that we want the
government to consider is taking equity
stakes in firms we've seen this in
France with Renault in Germany with
Lufthansa and of course the United
States is considering it on the back of
what they did back when we had the
financial crash and they took equity
stakes because we know that too many
firms are afraid of getting loaded up
with debt we don't want to see them go
to the wall we don't
people unemployed and of course young
people in particular are really at risk
in this crisis at the same time we know
the government's already spent billions
of pounds directly paying people's wages
figures out this week showed that UK
debt is now bigger than the entire
economy there is only so much the
government can do it that well this is
not the time to take the foot off the
pedal what we know is that the furlough
scheme has protected jobs it's got a
strong record not just in this country
but elsewhere of allowing the economy to
bounce back quicker as well as
protecting working families but you know
what we've got to do is make sure that
we avoid the cost of long term
unemployment we in fact angular Merkel
was talking about this just this week
that she was worried that governments
are not seeing the toll that would take
for the long term on our economies and
you know perhaps we shouldn't just be
looking at the 1980s as a situation that
we want to avoid and need to invest in
to avoid but this could be as bad as the
1930s if we don't get our act together
and come together we want to see the
government setting up national councils
this should be a national effort for
recovery and reconstruction of this
country to build back better fairer
greener economy that delivers good jobs
for people you mentioned a little bit
earlier in the interview I had the need
for workers to feel that they can go
back to work safely what needs to be
done to convince people that they are
safe at work well I'd like to see again
the government get its act together you
know that test race isolate scheme where
is it we need it up and running that's
absolutely critical to the
infrastructure to ensure that people are
safe we've argued and the government
agreed that risk assessment should be
published but I'm afraid as we published
last week that too many firms and big
high-profile names have not published
their risk assessments that doesn't give
me confidence or the work force
the local communities that they operate
in confidence that they are taking
safety seriously enough yet and yet that
is the quickest way to get people back
to work and our economy back up on its
feet another way to get the economy back
up and running is for children to go
back to school as well that's isn't
going to be happening until September
for many many children and some people
are laying the blame at the door of the
teaching unit in this do you think that
they should have done more to try and
get schools back
well again only just this week teaching
and education unions have been arguing
for ketchup schemes over the summer and
it would be great to see the government
pay attention to some of those practical
ideas drawing on the practical
experience of Education staff about how
we can support children in this
extraordinary period but yes again i'ma
trace some of these problems at least
that's about basic issue meaningful
consultation involving people getting a
sense that we genuinely are all in this
together and can solve the problem so
that we do the right thing by our
children and that's by making sure that
schools are safe it is about being
imaginative about summer play schemes
why did we have to fight so hard and
depend on one of our footballer members
to make the case for free school meals
over the summer but it's common sense
that we should be putting kids first and
I know that education unions are
committed to that